hi I'm Alex I'm a tasty producer and
today I'm going to be making chocolate
janicoo sorry that I misspoke once hi
guys I'm Alex I'm a tasty hi guys I'm
out okay hi guys I'm Alex I'm a TV
producer and today I'm going to make
sorry that I misspoke once honestly this
intro is gonna be harder than the damn
chocolate croissants okay
[Music]
hi guys I'm Alex I'm a TC producer and
today I'm going to be making chocolate
croissants I've never made chocolate
croissants before I hear they are very
very difficult to make so this is going
to be great
I hear the hardest part about making
croissants is that you have to keep the
dough completely cold the whole time
even when you're like rolling it out and
you have to roll it out and fold it a
million times I've got that all mixed in
so here comes a trick you're gonna grate
the butter right into the dough
I've had this butter out for like a few
minutes and I already feel it's getting
a little bit warm I don't know where I
already went wrong and then I'm just
gonna kind of oh yeah that's way too wet
I think I need I don't claim to be a
good Baker please quote me on that
yeah it's a little tougher to grate in
which is good I think right it's also a
good workout good arm workout this is
good though if you make your own
croissants then you can eat them too
because you'll have worked out its
cracking a little bit I don't know if
that's a bad thing but we're going with
it okay so now I got it we got to work
fast actually okay I'm wrapping so I
think I was supposed to flour the
surface actually so let's rewind and I'm
also gonna flour the rolling pin because
you don't want it to stick okay
that's hard I am not exaggerating right
now okay we got a surface literally bent
from the dough where my muscles muscles
okay it's going a little lies are all
breaking I'm gonna just try to push it
back together I still don't want to give
up that's like the crazy thing but this
dough I think oh okay here's what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna chill it again
okay apparently this rolling bin sucks
so I'm gonna try it with this one it's
looking good though
myself see this is why you don't give up
on anything
I probably shouldn't speak too soon yeah
ever again
really now I have to put this in the
refrigerator overnight and pray that it
comes out tomorrow and if you notice I'm
not wearing black today trying to avoid
the fingerprints now if we're rolling it
out it's cold so I'm anticipating this
gonna be hard again up never gets easier
well this is awkward
it looks like a dress or something an
hourglass not the figure you would have
if you a chocolate croissant but if you
make them now
that is the key this is a workout let me
tell ya continue to roll I'm baking
these at 450 okay um I don't know where
any of the flakes are looks pretty much
like an Olive Garden breadsticks how
many times did you I lost count I think
it's getting too soft
super-dense
okay yeah yeah maybe that'll be a tasty
video cinnamon roll croissants why do
people keep saying this
why does hey don't look so Jane key just
pop like a pimple well I was trying to
make a one day may take a year or two
god I'm gonna have croissants so the
butter leaked out butter many of you may
be wondering why I haven't just given up
I've wondered the same thing myself
but it's my job so I can't he doesn't
have a mental breakdown
we are here and hopefully the last day
of let's go get the dough where did I
put it oh my god wait this is so
embarrassing
oh there it is okay I forgot that I gave
it like a last little freeze I know a
big problem that I've had is keeping
everything really cold working in this
kitchen it's always hot that's one thing
I know I can't really control but it's
something that's probably affecting it
you need to make sure the layer of
butter doesn't melt into the dough
because when it bakes the layer of
butter will melt and create co2 which
puffs up the croissants and makes them
really flaky I don't need the flaky
croissant in the world I just want a
little flakiness
oh I'm asking for it I don't want to
speak too soon but I see some layers Wow
the layers look really nice actually
okay
I worked hard for those layers I ate
half of this part last night so we have
one and a half hours of chocolate
so it's time it's been about 20 minutes
baking I'm gonna go look at them pull
them out I haven't peaked yet so I'm
really hoping they puffed up don't look
good oh my god
[Music]
no trip keep it coming keep it coming
people yeah Chris once again any time
for that now it's just smooth sailing
sorry I'm a little loopy I've done this
too many times taken me eight days nine
days to make these croissant and I've
learned anything in those nine days in
fact support your local Baker but I earn
these layers and I'm proud of myself
and that's a big accomplishment so
[Music]
that's a wrap oh yes
go back